we got them at Uber all the way from
Newport California he is fighting for
the bantamweight championship of the
world in the UFC against sugar Shawn
this week's food truck Dyer is my boy
Tito Vera and I'm feeding him Tacos El
Don let's go
[Music]
Mr Chino Vera what's up brother hey man
good to see you man you got a nice glow
about you I am nice glow man and you
brought the best sneakers I think we've
had on the show these aren't even out by
time this comes out ah they might be out
do they drop this week or next week I
believe the 31st that's what I saw in
complex I'm so jelly it's hard to make
me jealous but the Supreme dunks are
some of my faves bro you're crushing it
can I see you on Instagram you were you
were Zach Brian I performed it you you
got up there and said what happened his
stage of sin what officially I'm a
member you're a member of the band of
the sex brand band dang dude I might
switch careers man dude the white people
just embraced after that the white
people like yes
hey that's the market you need hell yeah
so you're coming off this huge win over
Pedro Munoz huge win especially it's
just perfect timing because you get a
win over a real vet like Pedro Munoz
who's not an easy night in the office
he's such a tough character and you look
good in that fight because it was
important it lined up because in the
main event you had aljo versus sugar
shine before I get your thoughts on that
I I thought it was a matter of time
before sugar became champ down the road
I think it'd be against al Jermaine I
thought aljo just stylistically was
giving me a nightmare of a match-up form
I just I didn't see it going like that I
thought again I thought sugar was a meat
chip just not doing it the way he did
good so for you to get that win over
Pedro then aljo and sugar to be the main
event it's just like this it's this
perfect path it's business for you it's
dude it's business is a booming business
is a booming and then and then to you
know for your benefit sugar wins gets on
the might it was like cheetah one night
right was it boring he's like yeah I
want him next and it's like oh this is
fantastic I mean he's he said in the
fight already you know what I'm saying
like that's business is right there I
get it
I'm the number one Contender it doesn't
matter it doesn't matter it's all
business it's fighting it's a show and I
gotta win over him so it's a perfect
time to do it but if you ask me I'm not
pushing it I'm not [__] going
desperate online going like this is my
time look yeah I hate that I don't even
I don't like that I don't do that I'm
just like nor do you need to I Don't
Give a [__] well he did it for you
exactly he was like he was like Cheeto
one tonight right yeah he's next I was
like yeah oh what I looked at the boy on
a group time like here we go our boys in
like it went when the champ wants
something they're gonna do it and the
back story there you have a win over him
I know he doesn't you know admit to it
but you do have a win over him you guys
have this beef so there's a good
narrative to the build up too it's so
easy to magnify right now especially
there's a ton of implications
there's the most money to make is right
now it's right now it's the latter we
don't know what's gonna happen we're
going to talk all we want we're going to
be all Mystic man whatever the [__]
we're gonna be you just don't know
what's gonna happen later that's what we
got to do so you're coming off when he
got the biggest one of his career you
ever went over him he's talking about
December it works out for you guys I
don't know if you're down with how you
feel about it for December the month
before the month after this month
I prove that but go in front a huge
fight in Harrison agree to go down to
Paramus same toughness maybe better to
strike him for Munoz Jose stuff Pedro's
top it's tough I I put him on on the
skate on the third one I really heard
him his eyes roll and he just goes like
back to normal head down it sounds as
tough as they get nobody looks good
against Pedro I'm not saying anything
I'm saying as far as like a showcase
fight where you where it's like this
clean no one walks out of fight with
Pedro clean yeah he's a dog half a
strong head in terms of like mine yeah
you can take a dude I I punch him really
hard on the jaw I jab him like a
thousand times on the mouth he just
refuse to go down and in the third round
his eyes raw he kind of went like that
and someone just back up I'm like okay
dude you want to go to these things you
put it on him I give it to you you put
it on him at the right time when you uh
watch the sugar fight you're watching
backstage I actually did all my media my
pictures and I just left somebody to me
like maybe stay maybe do the octane
thing I'm like I don't want to [__]
cheerleader that's not your thing I went
back to the hotel get shelters with my
family smoke some weed eat some
mushrooms and I was [__] you we
didn't watch the fight first round was
back and forth I think on Miley won the
first round in terms of energy
audio striking
I respect it but it's so [__] bad
yeah he can fight I mean he he can find
he could throw he's a he's a tough guy
but he don't know how to sit in the park
and just paint with um you've been in
front of another fight and just be like
foreign
you feel that when somebody's like let's
forget about punching I just want to
grab you that's so easy to deal with
especially as a striker it's sunny all
day you gotta be like yeah yeah
I mean he goes he I think his mind
wasn't ready for the pressure of the
light for the magnitude of the event and
I believe
um aljamin [__] up he beats hero in
Brooklyn he should be
[__] you [__] you I'm fighting in
December you want to strip me Strip Me
agree 100 and he kind of like went like
oh I want to make a million or maybe
over I'm gonna just do it he's not just
about the money it's about also the
Legacy already had the money right he
already got a couple houses he's really
successful
don't [__] [__] yourself out for a
couple hundred years yeah don't don't
bend the knee especially when you're the
champ when you're reign in champ and
they're rushing anything remember he was
unhealthy he didn't want the fight and
then the US is like nope the UFC I
shouldn't push him he found him I'll be
like you have two options have him wait
for December or have him fight for the
intern Bell and he made me December
already streamed me and I just fight the
winner in December I agree he's the same
I agree he's a [__] thing it's a it's
a real miscalculation
it's on him it's us on his team because
as a fighter you guys want to like
you'll fight tomorrow you'll fight sugar
tomorrow you don't care you'll fight
freaking Jon Jones tomorrow you don't
care that's why you need a team to go
algae listen we know the UFC's putting
pressure in the fight to fight sugar
he's been preparing for you for a year
he's had a year to game plan for you
yeah you're not healthy you don't want
to cut this weight let's just wait till
December
your body cannot hold up you need that
time of reset put all the nutrients back
eat good
and then go back in you can just go boom
boom especially if it's a big white cut
he's a big boy he's already won seven
yeah yeah and I feel he's [__] up
because now he's like kind of like
making that part of his gig like oh look
I'm fine I'm 170 I'm like that's not
good we're gonna fight that's it stick
to what make you famous yeah don't be
this fat guy that turns it off I agree
[Music]
were you surprised the way sugar got it
done no really I honestly thought it
could be either way it could be like
that or get over and over because if
Peter Young is able to wrestle you like
that you're assuming somebody like oh
you can correct but the only difference
like Peter is a real fight you can see
it he can bugs he can pimp it's a
different style the only thing on the
Sean Peter is a size difference that's
why I think he also it was perfect but
making let's jump to number one
Contender against the smallest guy in
the division yep but if I want to be a
Matchmaker I would do the same yeah I'm
with the UFC because sugar is good for
business all right and it's also good
for you it's great for me I talk to the
day before I went like this
and we win and we perform so now it's
really up to the UFC they call the shot
let's be honest there's no there's
nobody out there going like hey this is
going to happen no no no people don't
understand that no no they don't they
don't they're like dude you should call
I'm like settle down
let the let the people let people do
their job yeah like like sugar going I
want Cheeto next that's great and he
puts the idea and you'll see it makes
sense too like it's not like it's some
random call out like there's a history
there so the UFC goes that makes sense
and and judo's coming off a win that
makes sense let's do it now if you
weren't my boy I have an argument I
could make for murab I have an argument
I make for uh Corey sandhagen so since
he was 17. I can have an argument a deep
argument with anybody you want for marab
and Corey sandagan 100 how are you you
especially as business-wise all day
you're the clear-cut winner
business-wise
but guess what him and all you are
playing ball now oh you're my best
friend oh uh if my boyfriend gonna fight
again very much I give it to my best
friend oh no but I'm gonna do my best
friend to the service like I quit
talking to his dick then it's already
pissed yeah
and if you know Dana it's like he hates
that he hated dick sucking hey guys quit
it's talking to Thursday who's fighting
but they're like playing ball and again
that benefits me agree but that sent me
that clip this morning they're not
talking on containers and I'm like we're
good bubble yeah you're really good
brother and then you're talking about
life-changing like you do you use the
title Bubba like you're already Tom
Cruise in Ecuador I mean you are 2.0 you
want money back bro what are we gonna do
what are we gonna do in that new house
those white people definitely know you
then yeah the neighborhood yeah that
neighborhood though now let me feed you
before you get too rich to come back on
the show and too famous let me feed you
some time yeah that's about 100 and 100
degrees out here it's about to get to
105 so we're gonna get inside but let's
do it we'll hit some food
all right
[Music]
what's up brother what's up brother how
are you I'm good man thanks for doing
this yes sir thanks for having us yeah
quite the line up here my man
how is the keto Taco pretty good it's
awesome man it's I'll do uh to the keto
tacos I'm between the quesadilla or the
burrito which one is the burrito is my
favorite item on the menu brother it
comes with asada al pastor cheese salsa
and cilantro guacamole and Fries inside
the burrito
let's do a side we got it stayed up
every single night and hustled every day
[Music]
food looks good brother like I was
telling you out there there's no in
between when if a food truck's bad it
goes south it goes Super South man let's
give it a try let's do it brother
because right now you I mean you're
always training you're always eating I
served this morning like for like two
hours yeah you're professional yeah I I
never jump in the sauna on these eyes
last night
and I've been fasting so I can eat this
food at least you know there's not gonna
be like short notice fights like that
you know no no not at this point anymore
no not the level you're at those those
days are gone uh how did you I got your
thoughts on how did you feel about sugar
as soon as he wins the fight uh shortly
after I don't know if that night but a
few days at least after that he was uh
vying for a fight with Javonte Davis a
boxing match I mean it's business right
just what we talked earlier about me
fighting for the bill not his business
that's
a lot of money
so he sees that business yeah that's
right guys get mad at it I mean
obviously very very very tough eyes
understatement for any of these MMA guys
trying to fight current in their Prime
boxers it's not a good idea I mean
there's no chances of that there's no
chance that's like me saying like yeah
I'm gonna compare that hit against
Kelly's later
oh [__] you Kelly I'm gonna talk [__]
you might as well say I'm gonna go big
wave surf like yeah there's no way to
work beating that wave I'm married
you'll die in that way correct but he's
like oh me personally let's go I I I'm
going to be it's insane it's just it's
[__] talking because both are competent
Sports make you think go play tennis
against [__] one of the wheels see
what happens yeah I know but the thing
is it's just the it's the it's kind of
the nature of the business now because
what Conor did everyone sees at the
level that he got to the money he's
making the notoriety so people go oh
that's the blueprint people wouldn't
have recorded he got to fight Floyd well
what's the next thing for me well
there's you know Devonte Davis there's
Tyson Fury so it's just the guys are
gravitating towards that now if the
money wasn't absolutely insane guys
wouldn't do that we sugar knows Francis
knows uh Connor knew these guys aren't
going to beat him but the amount of
eyeballs and PayDay
what happened to Corner after Floyd I
mean you whiskey company solid for a lot
look at him right now
is that worth it now
I mean you're rich but you can win a
fight
you lose
all the respect out there pretty much
I support what you think I'm like cool
dude you make it good for you I don't
hate it for that but
how what type of mindset is it right now
having everybody been like oh you can
win a fight the last Wing was car was a
run it's been a hot shot you know what
I'm saying it was a sacrifice to be that
rich yeah it's a blessing a curse heavy
lies the crown you like Batman
um it it's tough with Conor because if
I'm Connor
it has to be an ego thing and you know
that's what gets you into fighting and
that ego and that drives what makes you
guys great
but it's a it's the same thing like with
Tony Ferguson like that same desire and
the absolute Warrior kind of spirit is
what made Tony the best at one time
probably the greatest lightweight walk
in the earth that didn't get a title
right so it's not an intern title like
your legit title to me he was at that
time in his prime probably the best I
think it was a good matchup against
khabib I'd love to see that fight then
come to fruition but now that same
Warrior Spirit now he's hanging around
now he's upset if everyone says retire
Josh Thompson came out with a heartfelt
message like you just I'm telling you
you get yeah it's gonna affect your life
yeah and kids I mean you you get mad
because you know it's true I mean when
you're younger and you're that tell you
the truth or why you're getting bullish
or why you can do this and that you get
super much you say [__] your head you
and then you go when you grab your leg
he was right he was just give him advice
and trying to protect me but
when you're that old and you can't
figure it out just walk away don't don't
I mean it's okay to lose
a feel right after your Brine and you
keep trying but don't lose seven don't
lose ten I mean lost two and figured out
like you're not the same yeah but don't
say like oh I'm gonna be World Champion
by the end of the month it's not gonna
happen like that stuff and it's sad to
see guys so great he's one of my faves I
mean but look in boxing like Tyson
didn't really really lose like that he
lose few at the end but that's a few but
it wasn't so it wasn't like that didn't
get knocked out like it's bad and they
should since we were copying a lot of
bugs and also copy that return time like
I mean it's up to the to the Commission
in the UFC the same way Dana was like
with Chris Weidman was like I I don't
want to see him fight again but he want
to stop him from fight I know that's the
thing he's like
like
not a number of how many times you can
lose but like hey dude it's been a while
we recommend you to stop or use or just
cut them I mean at that level at that
losing the streak it's not like you're
going to lose money so what else I get
they usually probably have some love I'm
sure that you still love women
I love women I came to the locker room
I'm given her I don't know him I give
him a hug I'm like you're still a champ
keep your head up I love one his kids
were there his wife were there I was
like he's the best give love to people
yeah even I'm not in the good days
because that's the most important part
about giving love right it's easy to say
congress when somebody wins but
sometimes it's just time you just Just
Let It Go but maybe people don't want to
let it go because they don't have
nothing else to do correct when you're
in your brain and you're making money
you guys are chipping now you gotta
start investing you gotta say this you
guys are learning because we all know
this is only 2 36 37 that's about it for
everybody everybody yeah name me a 40
year old guy that comes and killed it
yeah well however she did a Glover there
but there's two cats in the [__] home
yeah this is exception but that's what
everybody they ride on the exception
right you know that's the bummer also
you know you're you're smart you know
like a lot of guys don't learn that
until they get out most pro pro athletes
don't there's a reason why the NFL guys
I mean they're young kids with all this
money they don't realize all right that
40 million mansion you bought that's a
30 40 year mortgage Bubba like you
you're gonna be like how long let's say
you have a phenomenal career to play 10
years I've heard of 10 years after that
you're still going to have this payment
every month yeah so what are you doing
to set yourself up so you can cover that
nut I mean you gotta
you gotta invest the right money you got
to get passive income back before you
play it's a big volume the problem with
that
is also a social media
you see
a boxer you like with like four
different watches that cost four hundred
thousand you're like oh I want that he
did something better than YouTube don't
compare yourself with that different pay
scale don't compare yourself with Drake
don't think like oh
isn't that I mean just be your [__]
self but social media make you see these
rappers that have
a chain with [__] seven pateks or
seven of those people are heroes
I mean is that good for you but also
people get confused when they don't have
a clear path or a clear personality they
go like well see I want that yeah you
want to take that equal success yeah
it's not equal and
we're not in the same road might take
you a couple years to do it might take
me 10 years to do it but at the end of
the day you will get there you you make
it happen if you just keep on season
then you start to compare yourself and
take a sugar level oh I want to be
brilliant shop oh I like the car you
have [__] the [__] guy work for that
yeah he's not you you be you and you get
what you want but is your boy Zach Brian
good with money
I don't I don't I'm sure he is he seems
like a really humble guy Loki he's
trying to
prove nothing I mean when he goes in
instead he prove you everything right
but the the small amount of we know each
other he seems like a pretty chill guy
he's not [__] because you're around
some successful guys that's why I asked
like he's like Brian obviously blowing
up Action Bronson he's been famous for a
heart and that's that's what I say about
people like a lot of people get really
popular for like this amount of time
like a couple months couple years
I like
guys like action Mr cartoon like they're
being famous their whole life like
you're wrong like they if you're famous
that much
because you know how you you know how to
work you know how to came back all of
those guys have probably have some
setbacks some financial problems at some
point some whatever but they figured it
out how to get up and keep going keep
blowing away and you can just expect
that to be you you gotta [__] work
for it okay so
back to fighting do you think
what do you do if you're Al Joe
what would you do I mean because the
only obviously you know I think you
should definitely get the title shot
is there any argument if let's take
yourself out of it that he you know he
had a good Reign man you know could be
regarded as one if not you know top two
best bandwidth of all time there's an
argument that he should get immediate
rematch you should but he don't know
what he wants I mean
this is my personal opinion before I
fight
you can let people know your plans you
can I'm a I'm not a fan of saying I'm
gonna return after this fight I'm not a
fan of saying I'm gonna go to these
workers after this Vibe because you're
putting out there in a way excuse
if you're losing I'm go I'm leaving
anyways you just gotta keep it to
yourself
and do everything to win
he was fully committing going to 45. and
now he's like oh I don't know you don't
play the game with the UFC no no no you
told him black or white you don't tell
them like grayish they don't like that
it's [__] you yeah
he should know what he wants I'm going
from there
because uh especially at 45 like even uh
woken off he was like yeah if you're the
one I would have entertained it but now
it's just it's not happening you're like
God if we go to 45 right now he's
probably getting somebody in the top 10.
he's not gonna get oh no he's not gonna
get a Tarot fight he's not gonna get a
big fight I mean you will sacrifice
versus volcanovski and or both of us
versus startling I mean the early to
purify is hard right now the guy can
fight the guy come box he shows good
skills he's a tough guy he comes ready
he's next for sure yeah yeah how would I
watch Al Joe for smack Holloway
[__] dude that's a fun night I mean it's
a [__] night but I I just feel mugs it's
just too big he's good I'm not offense
but if you don't take down the money you
don't want to take down [__] marks
let's be just honest and Max fights a
thousand times better than Sean he can
actually box he can beat the bug and he
can move he can get hit he fights
but I mean it's a big fight for uh if
you can do it I just don't see that as a
writer what do you think the UFC does
with maram
what do you do with them you wait for
Corey sandhagen to heal up and then you
have those two yeah it's just
if you ask me he should be going crazy
companion for the bill he's you go to
Vegas meet with them and be like hey
guys [__] off what are we doing
but he just kind of like playing ball
with his friend which I respect that but
he just doesn't work for business might
as well go to the workless up or below
but
I mean I think he was Bank on aljo
winning going up there now that kind of
you know with sugar upsetting his plans
are kind of like ah you can imagine now
if now now because those two because
aljo and marab are so close now it's put
a Holton morob's plans too because he's
like all right I'll just gonna win go to
uh you know go up a weight class and
then I'll be able to compete for the
title you know and for intern belt
against you or who you know who I mean
but then that doesn't happen so aljo's
still the weight class
I feel they [__] up they shouldn't be
playing these body game since the
beginning they I mean I get it but you
should know he's just doesn't maybe they
didn't knew it he used a word like that
and right now they're like
who's gonna fight for the Bell is my
team is gonna give it to me is my team's
gonna give it to him that's just so if I
came here they're gonna go like hey guys
and you can Bank on all my friends want
to win fighting is the only sport you
don't bank because [__] everything
happens sucks the bet on you I mean you
can it's it's not gonna I know there's
people that think they know what they're
doing
in fighting I don't give a [__] how much
of another dog or a favor you are it can
go south real quick too many ways to
lose too many ways to lose and
you and also there's a way I could
include you don't know which work is
gonna do your run you know which work is
going to be hard you know when your
version are shut down people don't know
that even if you're the [__] favor
and you're the and you're supposed to
eat a life if you're weak that night
you're [__] yeah it's good and it's just
too many too many Burns and that's why I
haven't met one time ever in my life I
don't bet in fighting because people ask
me what do you think of it I tell you my
opinion as a professional but yeah it's
it's it's the worst sport to bet on and
people get on me like oh you're off on
that fight shop like yeah yeah yeah it
was off sometimes yeah yeah sometimes I
go for six sometimes I go four for six
it's it's just it's not football it's
not basketball like that that can help
you out on fighting it's tough it's
tough and the thing with that is like oh
you you say everything run yes I pick
all my friends
I'm super I'm the most biased
Alexander they go
who's my friend
[__] right now I forget let's see Luke
is fighting yeah and he's fighting
[__] who's the hardest I mean he's
fighting is he I'm your future your boy
yeah
I'm putting my whole heart on that I'll
argue jelly rolls better than Tupac
right now yeah I'm a piece of [__] yeah
I mean [__] you I'm gonna bet that's my
friend I didn't even know you a little
bit I don't want to upset you because I
already know you a little bit this guy
don't know that I'm not gonna beat you
I'm gonna still go with you because I
love you a little bit it is what it is
because you're a good friend
uh before we get you out of here if that
card comes to fruition December in
December the title fight that card's
pretty stacked I've seen some rumors
what's going on on there you saw that
fake car they did they look pretty good
someone leaked this yeah they're like
nothing's official I don't think that's
gonna be the card it could be but if
it's just you know there's some big you
got caught on there
I don't even know if that's official yet
so you got Connor Chandler do you think
hey do you think that fight happens
I mean it's tough who knows
who knows who knows and Conor is like
you see him drunk you see him turning
you see him drunk you see him turn I get
it it's too much success too much
Freedom too much everything I look at
that angle good for you well I love it
bro
yeah I don't hate you it'd be good for a
business for you if it's a if it's that
because if you do Conor Chandler and you
also got you and sugar on there we're
going Sizzler then yeah we're buying
another house in Newport after that oh
yeah
you know what I'm saying like that
card's insane that's crazy to be on a
Connor card and if they mix Connor and
sugar who are like these massive names
you know it's not and between then two
is like they're they're kind of like
support each other but when it comes
down to paper reports and I'll be like
oh it's like two hot chicks in a room
you can't do that yeah there's not
enough cameras yeah people people think
that's a good thing that that's gonna
end sword run yeah it's like almost five
seconds
yeah I was like hey
it's gonna end really good when you hear
you say that uh before we get you out of
here it's John Strickland used to be a
Rooker guy he's a Vegas guy now fighting
Izzy next Saturday predictions I gotta
go with my boy easy nice and clean yeah
I I like it fighting you never enough
you never know and I learned the hard
way all right took some heat online
because I picked the algae over uh sugar
but
um you never know but just when you look
at stylus ski I just don't
I don't see a path of Victory because
even with Al Joe and Suga you'd go yeah
sugar lands this thing's over
but with sugar I'm sorry with Sean
Strickland you don't go oh if he lands
it's over that's nice he's not not ours
he would like he will break down yeah
he's a volume puncher so I guess well he
can break Izzy with his pressure now
we've seen guys he moved to his League
again you never forget no can uh Sean
Strickland get done
and with the cell Bender all the way so
we'll see well
you're trying to campaign before you're
fighting to Sam in December but uh I
hope you get the fight brother thank you
brother love your cakes y'all class me
you're the best man appreciate you
cheater everybody